I'm back to break down my probably flawed understanding
of Portugal's 2024 legislative elections.
As I said before,
if I say anything wrong,
please correct me in the comments.
I just wanna learn
and have a discussion to help everyone understand
this crazy show that's going on a little bit more.
So these are the relevant parties and coalitions
which I went over my last video,
so check out part 1
if you're still a little bit confused here.
Snap legislative elections
were held on March 10th, 2024.
Snap meaning these were not supposed to happen,
but because we lost our prime minister in November,
they happened anyway.
And AD and PS won the most votes. So AD,
the Democratic Alliance
and the Socialist Party.
And so they also
because they won the most votes,
they also win the most seats in parliament.
So 77 for PS and 79 for AD.
What's interesting
is that SHEGA had a big boost in their vote count.
So you can see from 2022 to 2024
it went from 12 seats to 48,
which is a lot.
And then PS,
which is usually one of the most popular parties,
decrease substantially
from 117 to 77.
Either way, there's not a clear majority here.
So in conclusion,
Portugal voted farther right than they did last time.
And really since they have in a really long time.
Stick around for Part 3
so we can talk about what this actually means
for Portugal.